no your eyes are not deceiving you that
is Bruce Willis and Demi Moore
Quarantine E with their kids and yes
they are wearing matching pajamas and
I'm wearing my the famous X's posed
alongside their 28 year old daughter
scout youngest daughter Tallulah's
boyfriend Dylan bus and several of the
family pets all sporting identical green
and white striped PJs even one of the
dogs had its own night shirt
Tallulah posted the cute family photo to
Instagram on Monday with the caption
chaotic neutral and no bad blood here
Bruce's wife Emma commented on the pic
writing not many can pull that color off
looking good squad but wait there is
more
Tallulah posted a larger portrait or
Instagram stories this time including
scouts boyfriend Jake and a giant fork
and spoon
Demi also Instagram the pic calling this
time in their lives family bonding
the only Willis missing from the family
photo session is a 31 year old groomer
but don't worry she has been spending
plenty of time with her family during
quarantine last week the former Dancing
with the Stars champ posted this selfie
with Tallulah sitting behind her rumor
has also appeared in several of her
famous moms posts here she is singing
with her sisters
[Music]
[Applause]
the 57 year old also shared this photo
of her quarantine crew working on a
family photo project now ask for Bruce
and Demi of course they were married
from 1987 to 2000 and they've remained
close through the years as they continue
to co-parent their three daughters I
hope that through my actions and how I
live one creates a you know clearer path
for them and that it inspires them to be
the beautiful powerful young women that
they are here they are celebrating
Tallulah's birthday back in February
Bruce's current wife Emma Heming was
actually the one who posted the photo of
their blended family
she and Bruce tied the knot in 2009 and
had two daughters of their own of course
Demi was also remarried to actor Ashton
Kutcher from 2005 until 2013
[Music]